et
là vous avez gagné
votre poids en huîtres
[Musique]
donc les deux colis piégés par park et
je suis le seul à savoir où les et place
est évidemment
[Musique]
grâce à la traçabilité obligatoire que
nous avons sur nos coquillages ça ne
pouvoir me permettre de remonter jusqu'à
la personne indélicate un professionnel
de la mer ou pas qui les aura vendu dans
une grossiste qui lui-même leur a vendu
un poissonnier et avec l'aide de la de
la brigade nautique et la gendarmerie
maritime nous allons pouvoir interpeller
depuis 2016 où nous avions des centaines
de kilos volet on
chaque année on a une des ses grilles
pardon dégressivité
de vol et donc nous sommes arrivés
maintenant à la une dernière c'était
encore quelques vols de connu mais très
peu hein
on va dire au moins de 5 cette année
enfin fin 2020 il y en a pas eu pour
quasiment